Ist bei dir auf der Arbeit was spannendes passiert?
Was ist deine andere Arbeit?
Das Dokker-File, das sie geliefert haben, war kaputt.
Das Dokter-File, das sie geliefert haben, war kaputt.
dass das Zentrale ist,
Evaluierung eines neuen Hosting-Anbieters
oder neuer E-Mail-Anbieters
oder neuer Infrastruktur-Providers
oder was auch immer.
Also lassen wir kurz gucken, was Trende
und vor ein paar Tagen kam das neue Zelda raus.
Also, das wundert mich nicht...
Du kannst auch Konzeption schreiben
oder Pog ist auch sehr beliebt für Proof of Concept
aber schreibt Konzeption!
Ist vielleicht nicht verkehrt...
Dann ist das wahrscheinlich besser als auf der Switch zu spielen...
Ich wollte mir gestern den aktuellen Dungeons & Dragons Film angucken.
Und dann habe ich erst mal festgestellt, dass Release nur in den USA war.
Ich konnte den Film auch mieten
Und jetzt kommt der Hit
Trailer hatte ich ja abgespielt, Trailer super Bildqualität
1080p bis zu 4k, überhaupt kein Problem
Dann starte ich den Film...
... und der Film ist auf einmal in...
... 480p
Dann denke ich mir so, hä?
Naja das ging doch eben auch?
Hmm, komisch
Naja okay, habe ich dann mal den Browser zugemacht
Und dann hab ich festgestellt wenn man den Film gekauft hat
Trick 17
wenn ihr den Film gekauft habt dann braucht ihr kein Vpn mehr zu gucken über YouTube
Ich habe Chrome benutzt ja
Offiziellen Chrome
Also man braucht kein Vpn mehr zum gucken, man braucht nur das Vpn zum kaufen
Also bin ich ans Handy gegangen, hab den Film abgespielt übers Handy
1080p, gar kein Problem
Und dann hab ich festgestellt
Die gibt es in YouTube
bzw. in in diesem YouTube
ähh Filme
Filme Verleih Portal
Auf dem Desktop laufen Filme
weil sie DRM Probleme haben
nur in 480p
Das steht nirgendwo
innovate
und der Trailer läuft auch
in 1080p 4K
Das steht nirgendwo
Du guckst den Trailer
Du denkstared
Ich guck mir das jetzt an
4K, gar kein Ding
Im Browser, ich hab mich auch in edge eingeloggt
Im Browser ist es limitiert
Es gibt zurzeit keine Möglichkeit
gekaufte Filme auf YouTube
auf dem Desktop
Date, die Beste Variante
Ich hätt es am liebsten
auf dem Rechner geguckt, aber
Ging nicht
Weil man wieder so krass gegengelt wird
Was was für ein Akt
war diesen Scheiß
über VPN zu kaufen
zu bezahlen und dann in ordentlicher Auflösung zu gucken
Die muss ich
Da muss sich wirklich keiner wundern
Wenn die Leute
einfach mal bei DuKDaGo
blablabla
und sich das bei irgendeinem Streaming
Anbieter, bei ein illegalen Streaming Anbieter reinziehen
da musst du dich doch nicht wundern
Wenn's den Leuten so schwer macht
den Krempel
legal
zu gucken
Außer ich will ja nicht ins Kino gehen
irgendwie dann abends
da gestern alleine
Obwohl das glaub ich noch im Kino läuft
deswegen wahrscheinlich's ja auch noch nicht in Deutschland gibt
aber die Blu-Ray gibt's auch schon
ich versteh die Logik eh nicht, wie was released wird
also wenn man das schon so komisch
Weltreit-released
dann es den Leuten so schwer macht
ey pff keine Ahnung
wahrscheinlich hätt' ich's mir einfacher
Ich hab da bestimmt 45 Minuten
rumgebastelt, bis ich anfangen konnte zu gucken
also hätt' ich das einfach mal
kurze Suche Dr. Go
wo man das
gucken kann
und hätt's mir bei ihnen
in der Streamingseite angeguckt
hätt' zwei Minuten gedauert
ich hätt' den Film wahrscheinlich
in ähnlicher Qualität
und kostenlos ohne große Probleme gucken können
also da müssen sie sich echt fragen
Machen sie es nicht so kompliziert
dass man die Leute quasi da hintreibt
sich die Sachen illegal anzugucken
Also, das versteh ich nicht
Na ja, zumindest, unter dem Strich muss ich sagen
Der Film war gar nicht schlecht
Also, ich hab' ja gar nicht mit
so viel gerechnet
weil...
also...
Ich mein den hier
den hier
Ich hab hier, ehrlich gesagt
bei so nem Franchise-Film
gar nicht mit so viel gerechnet
Aber der war gar nicht übel
Also, für so, für so
wie nennt man das so
Für so ne
Ich spoiler nicht
keine Spoiler, Leute
Keine Ahnung
Keine Sorge
Aber war echt
nicht schlecht
Es gab ja mal so ein D&D-Film
2000-rum
und der war mega beschissen
und ich hab' eigentlich mit nichts
mit nix gutem gerechnet
aber insgesamt war wirklich gut gemacht
und und was halt cool war
was halt cool war, wie gesagt keine Spoiler
macht euch keine Sorgen
Aber eine Sache
die kein Spoiler ist
was mega nice war
Wenn man sich ein bisschen so im
mit dem
mit dem Dungeons & Dragons Regelwerk auskennt
und wenn man so ein bisschen
so die Forgotten Realms
Lore so so ein bisschen kennt
man muss halt nicht so der Hardcore-D&D-Spieler sein
ist mega cool gemacht
weil
sie haben sehr viel in dem Film drin
was halt so eins zu eins
ich nenn's mal so aus dem eigentlichen
Regelwerk aus dem eigentlichen Game ist
was für Leute die das nicht kennen
die denken es sich so
muss ich sagen
wird das ganze immer mehr verwässert
sodass du 30 Abos bräuchtest
wenn du die ganzen Sachen gucken willst
also apple plus haben wir auch noch
vergessen hier oben in der Aufzählung
gibt es ja auch noch
deswegen wäre es mir eigentlich ganz
recht wenn die vielleicht so
Exklusivgraben machen ist dann ein
premium Abo dabei bei dem Hauptdienst
aber wenigstens das man es woanders
leihen oder kaufen kann
wäre doch okay
es darf auch in Euro teurer sein oder
zwei das dass die irgendwie versuchen
aber dieses gibt es gar nicht mehr
auch releases wenn ich mir das angucke
dass Sachen releast werden allerdings
USA only im Stream in Deutschland gibt
es das ganze
allerdings erst mal nur auf blu-ray noch
nicht als streaming
das sind so dinge die ich denke
wir haben das Jahr 2023
wenn ihr was releast dann regelst den scheiß
ich bezahle ja auch Geld für
aber geht mir nicht auf den Keks
und dann kommt nicht auf so blöde Ideen wie
was es auch teilweise auch gibt
Deutschland releast
allerdings dann ohne
ohne urinal Tonspur und sowas
wo man sich immer denkt was ist denn mit euch los
ich kann es mir im Urinal nicht angucken
außer VPN und Kreditkartentricks
ich kann es mir in Deutschland nicht kaufen
weil Urinal Tonspur fehlt
das ist dann immer richtig schlimm
die wollen teilweise dass man es
sich illegal irgendwo anguckt
tja das ist halt ziemlich bescheuert
Na gut! Ich wollte mir ja die Trends auf GitHub angucken
also stehen wir so wie gesagt
Nintendo Switch Emulator wundert mich nicht
GPT Al, AI wundert mich nicht
AI wundert mich nicht
AI
Wie gesagt ich hätte jetzt vermutet
Ich hätte vermutet SUDO ist
1, 2 Dateien mit 400 Zeilen und gut ist
Na gut dann macht's vielleicht doch Sinn
Wie umfangreich ist
Ja das ist ziemlich
Das ist ziemlich kurz und knackig oder
Das Sudo
Wobei mir das schon ein bisschen zu
kurz vorkommt
Das erscheint mir schon fast ein bisschen zu wenig
Aber anscheinend ist das so
Ach nee LIP
Ne hier ist es alles drinne
Hier ist es ok ok ok ok
Sus genau hier ist alles drinne
Okay alles klar ja doch
Hät mich jetzt nämlich auch gewundert wenn das wirklich schon alles wäre
Ja okay das ergibt schon mehr Sinn
Regex diction
AI AI
Noch einen Switchemulator
hmm warum wohl
Blockchain Krampel
Ein World of Warcraft
FreeShot
Backend
oder sowas
Vermute ich mal
Welchen Prozessor hast du noch mal drin in deinem neuen
genau Ausrufezeichen
PC
Excellent
Oh Leute
Ist das überhaupt schon der RefLink
den wir hier angepasst
das ist nicht der RefLink
Modgis
Haben wir Modgis da
Wir müssen unbedingt was anpassen
Wir müssen
Ja
Nee, Moment
Ist das jetzt überhaupt ein Ratflink oder nicht?
Also...
wir müssen
imprisonen
ok
Wir müssen
entsprechende
gefördert gehen
Ich verstehe das nicht
Okay
Ja doch das ist ein Ratflink
alles klar
Ist das hier auch ein Ratflink?
Alles klar
Ratflink
Exzellent
Schon gedacht
Wenn ich schon einen Ratflink habe
dann kann man den Ratflink
Ja auch ein bisschen unter die Leute bringen
Okay alles
Dann brauchen wir doch keine Mortgages
dann ist doch alles richtig
Du es, das kenne ich
Das coole an Sudoware马 suitable ist eben an die Formen ist
da kannst eich darauf verlassen
Für deine lokale Kiste kann man das machen
Deswegen ist halt auch fraglich
ob so ein Rust Rewrite was bringt
weil das so tief in den Distributionen verankert ist
dass die das nicht austauschen werden
Blockchain
Das stellt halt ganz hart in Frage
kauf ich mir die ersten 3 Jahre ne neue Konsole wenn sie rauskommt
Also ich halte es für keine schlaue Idee
ne PS 5 Pro ranzubringen
zumal man sagen muss
die PS 5 ist performance technisch wirklich vollkommen in Ordnung
also es macht auch
eigentlich überhaupt keinen
grossartigen Sinn
außer alle abzufacken
Ich meine, ich glaube kaum dass ein Käufer
der originalen Konsole dann sagen wird
Ach, nicht so schlimm, dass ich die Sachen
nur in 30, anstatt 60 FPS spielen kann
oder nur in 1080p, anstatt in 4K
Es ist ja nur ein Zwischenrelease
das macht es für dich nicht weniger beschissen, ja?
Also insofern. Kannste knicken
find ich ... find ich keine gute Idee
und ich glaube auch nicht
dass das langfristig
für die Plattform gut ist
Ja
So sieht das aus
Leute was gucken wir uns?
Komm wir gucken uns jetzt mal ein paar Videos an
Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Das FDP-Manifest
Oh ne
Das muss heute morgen nicht sein
Mein ex Azubi packt aus
Herr Endpunkt, spricht Klartext
Okay, nice dass mir meine eigenen Videos empfohlen werden
Okay, Viewtime Leute
Excellent wir haben das jetzt geguckt
Okay, nice
Ein 10-Watt-Hair-Approxis-Cluster
Ach das sind diese komischen Boards
die wir letzten schonmal hatten
wo ich nicht verstanden habe weil es diese Boards gibt
Aber POG
der Untergang von Nokia
Katastrophe
Gaming PC Kaufberatung bei Mediamarkt
Das Video ist bestimmt richtig G-Bait
Wir haben schon einige Videos geguckt, die waren immer vom Titel ziemlich
ziemlich G-bait, aber mal gucken
Also ist würde
Niemals zu Mediamarkt gehen
In der Hoffnung dass ich gut beraten werde
Zu Mediamarkt würde ich gehen, wenn ich kleinen Hardware Sachen auf die schnelle brauche
das es länger dauert
das es schneller geht als die bei Amazon zu bestellen
Das weiß ich nicht weil ich habe
mehr den Google DNS eingerichtet
Ich weiß nicht wie es ohne Google DNS ist
Öh
Was haben wir denn hier?
Lass mich raten
Die Crazy Announcements bei Google waren AI
Und vielleicht noch ein bisschen AI
11.11.023
Und ihr schaut nach dem Datenerweise
Und ihr schaut nach dem Datenesschein
Bei Google AdWords
...
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an den Zusammenschnitt von
mit Apple so easy
findet man gar nicht mehr
Warum findet man das nicht mehr?
Es gab mal so einen Zusammenschnitt von so ner Apple
Von so ner Apple-Präsentation
Wo die halt 800 mal gesagt haben, es ist so easy
Das wundert mich nicht
Was?
Dann gucke ich kein YouTube mehr
Dann werde ich kein YouTube mehr gucken
Doch realistisch betrachtet ich werde noch YouTube gucken, weil was willst du sonst gucken
Ich habe auch YouTube Premium. In Indien habe ich das gekauft
Ja, damit habe ich auch gerechnet das es demnächst kommt. Das gibt es ja jetzt schon als Third-Party-Browser Plugins und sowas, AI für alle möglichen Webseiten und auch für Google Docs und sowas. Das ist klar, dass es das geben wird
Leute, was ist White-Color-Productivity?
Wow Massive Raid, Alter! Jetzt geht es aber los, hier, Dankeschön!
Poggu, Solution, danke für den Raid!
Schön, dass ihr euren Weg her gefunden habt! Indirekt, über Bande, quasi!
Wir gucken uns gerade an, was Google für nuevo AI Produktes raushaut.
Um festzustellen, dass Google eigentlich nur sehr viel schwätzt
und was davon am Ende rauskommt, ja sei mal da hingestellt.
Wusste gar nicht, dass du auf Twitch bist? Doch ich bin schon eine ganze Weile auf Twitch, allerdings
ich heiße hier ja nicht MaxFPS, ich bin ja auch gar nicht MaxFPS, ich bin ja wubbl0rs, das darf man nicht vergessen!
Und deswegen checken das wahrscheinlich auch so wenige, wobei es immer mal wieder Leute gibt,
die das mitkriegen und sagen Moment, hä, ich kenne dich doch von Youtube.
Öh.. Das könnte sein. Was aber Absicht war, tatsächlich, ich hab mich absichtlich ein bisschen anders genannt,
weil auf Youtube gibt es schon sehr viele nervige Leute. Ich dachte mir so, wenn ich mich anders nenne,
also ursprünglich gab es den Account bevor ich angefangen habe zu streamen, deshalb hieß ich schon mal anders.
Aber ich habe den MaxFPS Account auf Twitch, den habe ich auch registriert. Also ich könnte mich umbenennen,
aber ich will gar nicht, weil es gibt auf Youtube schon viele nervige Leute und ich dachte mir,
hey, wenn man geistig erst mal diesen Transfer hinkriegen muss, der heißt anders aber es ist der Gleiche,
dann sind nur High IQ Leute da, das heißt Leute, ihr habt es jetzt gehört offiziell, ihr seid im High IQ Club.
Wer den Transfer, Haifert, ja, wer das hinbekommen hat.
Modkist sind auch da, sehr schön Modkist.
Magst ans Trinken erinnern, ja, Exzellent.
Du hast über ein Jahr für High IQ gebraucht, ja das macht ja nichts.
Besser spät High IQ als nie High IQ, würde ich mal sagen.
Aber der Chat, der kann ja auch noch upgraden.
Aber schön, dass Ihr da seid, wir gucken jetzt einfach weiter.
Da müsst Ihr los.
Ich hab letztens mal tatsächlich reingeguckt,
ähm, bei, was war das, League of Legends oder sowas.
Habe ich mir gedacht, League of Legends ist überhaupt nicht meins.
Also Mob fast.. Mob fast ist generell nicht meins.
Also beim Dany, hab ich letztens jetzt glaube ich League of Legends oder irgendwas angesagt
und das, nee, ist nicht, ist echt nicht meins.
Ich gerade war am Aktiv der AI Entwickungen, wo Elon Musk und irgendwie noch ein paar andere Dudes sich zusammengeschlossen haben.
Und haben gesagt, Hey, lass uns mal nicht so schnell angehen mit der AI Entwicklung.
Und ich wette mit euch Leute, der einzige Grund, warum der Kerl was geschrieben hat ist,
weil er selbst zur Zeit nicht im AI Game groß mit dabei ist.
Er war dabei bei der Gründung von OpenAI, also das sind die Chat-GPT-Leute.
Hat sich dann aber vorm Acker gemacht.
Und jetzt ist er halt ein bisschen angepisst und sobald der Typ was eigenes Konkurrenzfähiges am Start hat,
wette ich mit euch, wird das angepriesen als die geilste Erfindung ever.
Also ich vermute dahinter nicht jetzt wirklich Bedenken für die Menschheit,
die man sich jetzt darstellt, sondern schlicht und ergreifend, wer hätte es gedacht, Geld.
Man ist selbst Aktuell im AI-Business nicht so richtig drinnen.
Also macht man dann ein bisschen auf ethisch und flamet ein bisschen rum AI-Entwicklung ist scheiße,
und sobald man was eigenes hat, ach übrigens ich habe jetzt auch ein eigenes AI-Projekt,
die ist natürlich viel geiler, benutzt man meine, also da bin ich mir,
also kann sich natürlich nie, aber da bin ich mir 99 Prozent sicher,
sobald der Typ was hat, ist AI einfach das Beste was es gibt.
Der nicht mal Twitter-CEO ist?
Das stimmt, das habe ich gelesen, tatsächlich der ist nicht mehr Twitter-CEO,
allerdings das hat er ja schon angekündigt, er wird auf Twitter weiterhin an wichtigen Entscheidungen mitwirken,
was ich nicht so gut fand ist, es gab hier eine News, das Twitter umgebaut werden soll,
zu einer App-for-Everything oder sowas da.
Wo ich mir denke, ich brauche kein WeChat 2.0 oder so etwas in der Richtung, stellte er sich vor.
WeChat ist ja diese Chinesen-all-in-one-App,
die also mal angefangen hat als Chat-Applyation
und mittlerweile kannst du damit sogar deine Unterhosen bestellen quasi,
ehrlich gesagt, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob ich westliches WeChat haben will,
ob man Twitter zu einem westlichen WeChat umbauen sollte,
somal ich Twitter an sich ganz gut finde, so wie es ist,
also ich brauche Twitter gar nicht als WeChat-Konkurrenz,
...
Somal ich immer noch sagen muss, Twitter, Twitter an sich, Twitter an sich ist so ein richter Kackhaufen,
aber ich finde immer noch, auch nach der Übernahme,
und auch nach diesen ganzen Shit-Storms auf Twitter..
Ich mein twitter ist ja gefühlt 90% nur Shitstorm von einer Seite auf die andere,
aber trotzdem muss ich immer noch sagen, ich finde, nach wie vor ist Twitter immer noch das beste..
nennen wir es mal Social Network, wenn man das schön nennen kann..
ganz im Ernst, was hast du denn heute zur Auswahl?
Facebook?!
Also ich mein die Zoomer sind doch heute nicht mehr auf Facebook..
das ist sowas für die Omas ist Facebook heute angesagt..
...die irgendwelche Cringe-Boomer Witze posten...
Also Facebook ist ja nun wirklich nicht mehr angesagt..
So, was hast du sonst noch? Die Russen haben irgendwie ihr eigenes Ding?
Ich habs vergessen .. ich hab vergessen wie es heißt?
Die haben.. die haben doch auch ein eigenes Facebook, ich glaub das ist in Russland tatsächlich noch ganz beliebt.
Genau, das Ding! Ja.. Die haben ihr eigenes.. so.
Aber ansonsten.. was hast du denn noch für großartige Sachen?
die jungen Leute sind wahrscheinlich alle mehr oder weniger bei Tiktok und Instagram unterwegs..
Und, wisst ihr wo die Generation ist? Das finde ich auch interessant..
Weißt du, wo die Generation ist, die nach mir gekommen ist, aber noch vor der aktuellen Tiktok-Generation, also quasi die Leute die so sagen wir mal so zwischen.. zwischen 25 und 35 sind!
Genau! Die sind bei Snapdragon!
Niemand, ich hab den zumindest den Eindruck bei snapchat!
Ich.. ich hab so den Eindruck niemand außer dieser Generation feiern Snapchat ab!
Das sind die Leute, denen man damals erzählt hat, hey wenn ihr dick pics verschickt, dann verschickt die gefälligst über Snapchat, weil, weil in Snapchat kann man die ganzen Sache löschen.
Ja, genau.. das war.. das war so der Ursprung!
Hyper Gadgi! Das war so der Ursprung von Snapchat, ja?
So, und.. naja!
Ich glaub dem hat damals auch keiner erklärt, dass die Leute halt einfach Screenshots machen können.
Wobei das ja mittlerweile.. ich weiß.. Leute.. ich bin zwar Boomer.. für alle, die mich vielleicht noch früher von Youtube kennen, sage ichs noch offiziell.. ich werde 39 dieses Jahr, ja?
Kann man sich.. kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Aber.. ich bin.. ich bin eindeutig zu Boomer für Snapchat. Ich habt Snapchat auch nie wirklich verwendet.
Aber.. ich, ich geh ganz stark davon aus, dass die Leute ursprünglich mal auf Snapchat gekommen sind, wegen dieser.. du kannst Nachrichten mit Verfallsdatum versehen Funktion.
Dass man Screenshots machen kann, oder im Zweifelsfall das anderweitig speichern kann, sei mal dahingestellt.
Zumal Snapchat mittlerweile, auch schon ne Funktion drinne hatte, um Nachrichten wieder zu recovern, und sowas.
Also.. naja, gut, aber die Generation zwischen den Hyperzoomern aktuell, also zwischen denen, die beispielsweise den Fortnite-Loser dance vor der S-Bahn in Frankfurt machen..
Weiß nicht.. hatte ich euch ja auch glaub ich schon erzählt. Das war glaub ich so eines der cringesten Zoomer-Momente, die ich je hatte in meinem Leben.
Ich bin auf dem Heimweg, das war eh ein Tag, wenn ich dran erinnere..
Oh jetzt hab ich zu schnell geklickt!
170 ist ziemlich gut
Gar nicht mal übel
Ja, also hey ich weiß, obwohl ich Boomer bin Reaction-Times sind noch on point, ja Manuel
Man kogge Will noch wasen Aber Eines merke ich ohne Mist
War für Schooter auch für Spieleffizienz also ich würde sagen prinzipiell gilt das für soEi
also ich würde sagen prinzipiell gilt das für soEi
Und jetzt ist Apple die einzige Firma, die kein Foldable hat
Ich denke es ist eine Gewöhnungssache
Aber trotzdem
Ich komme aus der Generation da waren Foldables
also Klapphandys
Eigentlich ganz normal
und ich fand damals schon Klapphandys nicht sonderlich geil
Ich find Klapphandys nicht immer noch geil
Was auch witzig ist, dass wir in Deutschland xD
Die einzigen sind die das Wort Handy benutzen
Letztens gemietet
wie Gangster hatten
Wie hieß das Ding hier
Razor Klapp Handy
Dieser Ding in gold
Genau so ein Ding
Motoroller
Razor in Gold
das hatten so die ganzen Möchtegern
Gangster
Ihr auch?
horse Chomp
Nokia
Zwei
Ein chronischer
Erster
Zwei
Beste
Nokia
Sahib
Kalaration
Zwei
Geld
Fahrrad
Fahrradet
Ausführlichkeit
Fahrrad
Anhänger
Rad
Fahrrad
Fahrraad
Fahrcondors
Fahrrad
Fahrraad
Schnellfahren
Fahrrad
Fahrрач
Definition
Features
Auflöser
Auflüser
Anyway
Balcony
Justice
Debate
debate
amo
am
Am